oh
what's up guys can you hear me
do I sound fine
all right
yeah it's really early I'm tired
my eyes hurt
I beat Mortal Kombat one though
that was interesting
the iron bathrobe no I don't have that
do not have that
It's Five O'Clock in the morning here
I wasn't gonna make this video or live
stream this but
some people on Twitter said that they
would love
it so I was like
okay sure
yeah just me I doubt
anyone else Kings up but King King works
during the night so
he wouldn't be able to do it even if he
wanted to
do you want Fred
if you're gonna be up here you better
just lay down
better just lay down
just lay down Fred
uh the NZXT computer is a beast man it's
a beast
it starts at about 20 minutes I believe
it's supposed to start nine but we'll
see
we'll see guys
so here's Fred
say hi to the stream Fred
focus on Fred
there you go focus on Fred
's a nice little kitty
yeah it's Fred
he's a good cat
my girlfriend found some Stray Cats
so we uh
well their mom abandoned them
so that's what we've been doing is you
know
nursing them making sure they eat
one of them died unfortunately
uh but this one uh the the other three
seemed pretty strong
like our own
um I don't know who I don't know if my
girl named it or my brother's girlfriend
named him Fred
but his name's Fred
yeah you guys are three hours behind us
I hope there's nothing in this stream
that get the channel copy roach uh
claimed or God forbid a strike happened
you know how it would be so hard for me
to con uh to explain to Cog how we got a
copyright strike because I live reacted
to the Xbox Tokyo game show 2023
huh how Fred how would I explain that to
to Cog uh can you explain that to COG
can you explain it to [__]
I just beat Mortal Kombat that's what
I've been doing like the past hour
yeah I saw the profit share thing I
don't know nut enough about like
finances on a corporate level like that
to feel comfortable making comments
about that
better turn the sound down on I I will
if um
they start playing some stuff that uh
would be copyright
uh the copy the The Profit share thing
is there is uh supposedly and I don't
know because I'm not in the know when it
comes to stuff like this Microsoft
profited the uh
more money than PlayStation did
there's 2 500 people in this chat
considering America uh Xbox is an
American brand it's kind of impressive
that so many people are waiting for this
um
I ended up passing out like late last uh
early last night like at like 9 30. so I
woke up at like two so I was like I
might as well
stay up for this at this point
hello around the world yeah
uh put put in the chat where you guys
are from
let's get a
let's let's see how many countries is in
this chat right now
Ireland Alaska Germany
Canada Tampa Australia Australia South
Africa the Netherlands Portugal the UK
Tucson Arizona that's where I'm from Mr
BLT
I'm from Tucson Arizona
Finland
hey babe did I wake you up okay
I'm sorry
I went to bed like mad early yesterday
like 9 10.
been up since like three
say hi to the chat hi Chad
all right
I fed the kitten
hey
can you give me a water I would do it
myself but I would have to
this starts in like two minutes
all right guys
what what
last chance man last predictions thank
you babe
last predictions what we doing what's
being here
last predictions
do we reckon uh five dollar super trap
from Ice Cold uh cabbage
uh do we reckon Final Fantasy 7 or
rebirth is getting announced today has
Phil done it or can we get more info on
the Kojima project I've been told
there's going to be some
some uh one of the Bethesda you know how
like that
that leaked document had like a bunch of
like projects on it from Bethesda that
we didn't know the names for I've been
told one of those is supposed to be here
so we'll see if if that ends up being
sure or not
Odeon Chronicles Hunter
hello I don't know why my audio went out
like that
my zoom just turned off
how do I sound now
[Music]
all right I'm back okay
all right I'm gonna shrink me just a
little bit
and put me down here is that good
do you want me bigger do you want more
of the screen visible what would you
guys prefer
[Music]
okay
all right
all right here we go
[Music]
what do they open with
it's going to be a lot of reading let me
go up a little bit because I know
there's going to be a lot of captions
foreign
what is this
Ori
this is that game that just came out
Capcom
I never played these
did you guys play these
protect your innocent clients from false
accusations who's played these in the
chat
I know one of you have unreliable
oh my captions are in German
thank you for telling me guys
uncover the truth and Save the Day
it's coming to Game Pass
what is this
looks like Pokemon I know it's not but
it looks like Pokemon
oh in this Pokemon with guns I think I
heard about this somewhere
[Music]
who'd playing this
yeah
who play in this
coming to Game Pass
with the latest news from our Studios
and Publishing partners
thanks to everyone at CSA for your work
on behalf of game creators Publishers
and players
Japan will always have a special place
in my heart for pioneering innovative
ways to play from the Game Boy to PSP to
the switch
today's players want flexibility in
where and how they oh what are they
about to do Xbox our goal is to
continue our whether it's to announce a
handheld
with a wide range of amazing games
we've expanded PC game pass to 46
markets globally and over the past are
they going to announce a handheld
has more than quadrupled and PC game
path allows creators to bring amazing
new experiences to these players
we've also seen strong momentum for PC
gaming here in Japan
the Japanese PC gaming Market has
doubled in size over the last three
years
so we understand the importance of
making content that will appeal to
Japanese PC players for example
since the release of our Japan World
update for Microsoft flight simulator
nearly 15 million flights
raise the volume
thanks to our Innovations like Game Pass
Xbox cloud gaming you can play Fly
better simulator and many other games on
handheld devices mobile phones in
addition to traditional PCS and consoles
like the Xbox series X and Series S
we're also proud of our 2023 lineup of
games which includes Hi-Fi Rush the
recently released star field and the
upcoming Forza Motorsport
we're also grateful for the support from
our players in Japan Asia and Beyond NBA
remain committed to Bringing games
you'll love to Xbox
Arigato goza Mas and from everyone at
Team Xbox enjoy the show
all right let's see
oh four is a
[Music]
I did notice that they didn't they
didn't say anything about redfall
because
foreign
Atlas
produce
foreign
[Music]
RPG
Iving
questions
I hear you
Xbox knows Sarah Desu I am thrilled to
be back here at Tokyo don't you love how
like the Xbox executive say like once in
the Japan Japanese and then they just go
back to what they were doing across Asia
are a huge part of that in five years we
have more than doubled the number of
games on Xbox from this region and we
add more all the time from revered and
iconic Studios like metaphor re fantasio
from Sega Atlas in studio zero and the
like a dragon series from Sega and Ryuga
gotoku Studio wulong Fallen Dynasty from
Koi Tecmo sandland from Bandai Namco
armored Core 6 fires of Rubicon from
from software and Bandai Namco pubg
battlegrounds
and building off our Final Fantasy 14
announce in July we have a special
message from miyaki-san of Square Enix
foreign
[Music]
we love that acclaimed creators bring
their games to Game Pass day one like
hinitsugami path of the Goddess from
Capcom party animals from recreate games
and of course lies of P from neowitz
launched this week
and today we're honored to reveal
interviews with nitsumasan producer of
Persona 3 reload and new murasan
business producer for Persona 5 tactica
giving us extraordinary Peaks into their
creative process for the Beloved Persona
franchise
creators are the lifeblood of our
industry and our shares I noticed that
too celebrated
Indies we'll take to take the W's
question four creators
everyone is welcome
at our next game
via Wrath of the afari is an
action-adventure odyssey created by two
brothers that exudes their familial Bond
and passion for powerful storytelling
published by Neon Doctrine neon Doctrine
Arigato gozaimasu I actually have a
really good relationship with neon
doctor
they usually do horror games
[Music]
what's going on guys
foreign
[Music]
how we thought about this
I'm indifference
[Music]
I didn't say Game Pass
foreign
[Music]
it's hard to tell if we're gonna get hit
for
some kind of copyright claim because you
know how they love to do it
that one said Game Pass
op Atlas what's Atlas here for
Xbox One
is
foreign
so good so far TGs has been a good
little announcement
greetings to everyone at TGI Bethesda
with Fallout 76 we've explored
Appalachia we returned to the fan
favorite city of Pittsburgh and soon
we'll be showing our cards with an
all-new location
Atlantic City
since we announced Atlantic City at the
Xbox showcase last June we've upped the
ante with so much great content that
we're splitting it I know people
releases today I don't really want to
see Fallout 76 at these events on
December but they got to promote it
somewhere else stack the deck with new
content including new locations New
factions new creatures New Missions and
new rewards plus a flesh Casino where
our wastelanders can test their luck you
won't have to wait until December to
roll the dice in Atlantic City or
inviting anyone who already owns the
game on Steam to help test Atlantic City
On Our public testing server starting
October 3rd no thank you stay tuned in
to our social channels and fallout.com
for more details and may luck be with
you in Atlantic City later this year I'm
just saying it I get it they still got a
promoted man
the news of dad's death I plunge the
entire swen Clan into chaos
[Music]
this is only a job so don't take it
personally just accept your fate and die
rescue Volvo and the others
[Music]
I
will not allow you to proceed any
further oh
everybody
I like oolong I actually beat you along
you must not be so easily provoked by
the enemy I'll settle my score with him
later
boo boo was mad or annoying conqueror
growing into a fully fledged one causes
my Lord great distress
good game to show good game show
yeah the the Liza P collab I like these
Studios collab with each other
I really enjoy that is
foreign
things
let's do it
so
[Music]
like a dragon available
day one game pass yeah dude
foreign
[Music]
Chicago
name is
foreign
Kono
this is
going to be the same story
images
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I'm actually I'm down for this show
octopath travel to
um
the
game that's coming to Game Pass
they showed Wu long it's been a good one
so far
[Music]
oh
yeah the Pokemon game with guns
[Music]
new timer
for
eign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
what's next
yeah we gotta turn this down
unfortunately guys
this is definitely something that would
get hit
yeah they literally just did a Game Pass
ad kind of with the
the person before so like why are they
gonna do another game pass out
hello to everybody in our Japanese
Community I'm rich Lambert the creative
director on the Elder Scrolls Elder
Scrolls Online here at zoss we are
extremely excited to announce that come
November 15th ESO will be fully
localized in Japanese on the Xbox One
Xbox series X and S that's big for them
this is something that has been a long
time in the making that's big for them
extremely patient while waiting for this
and I don't know how popular like MMO
style games are in Japan this chapter
with a brand new class in The Arcanist
and we also have tons of new content
planned for the future so we really look
forward to seeing you all in Tamriel
soon and thank you for all your
continued support
foreign
I'm not a big fan of Pub G
so I roll my eyes every time I see pubg
I get it though
[Music]
what is this
everyone my name is from Game Changer
Studio we are a small easy game
developer with a team of around 10
people based in Indonesia we are behind
the trilogy of my lovely City
my lovely daughter and my lovely wife
are management games with
thought-provoking promise that seems
like outside of human relationship
we are now working on a new game my
lovely Empress where we took this
premise and evolve it to the next level
you are the emperor of the queen this is
interesting and you can resurrect your
beloved Fallen Empress at the price of
The Souls of your subjects
or betray your own to pursue a
relationship with leaders of other
nations across the empire
either way you will have to balance your
resources and handle difficult decisions
to keep your people growing I can see
this guy doing very well actually you
will be able to summon yaguay or Yokai
in Japanese
[Music]
inspired by ancient Asian myth those
alluring Godly being walking amongst
men's are capable of powerful magic and
hold the secrets of the darkest rituals
[Music]
we didn't just want to repeat what was
done before and me on the option our
publisher and co-development partner are
helping us to enhance the experience
including bringing the old wife the life
infinity seamlessly blending The Best of
Both Worlds the charm of 2D with the
immersive experience of 3D that's how we
found about this game what we're
creating allows us to not only honor the
original Vision this is a good Shout
so far so good so far so good pretty
special that will leave a lost in Impact
for our plans
I noticed that sucker didn't say game
pass on
actually a lot of people like this game
I didn't play it but a lot of people
liked it great job makes the pilot
have some self-respect and change up
your appearance
show your drought whatever new equipment
you get
the final mission will be Escape
enter the Escape device before it
deactivities
the Escape device will activate shortly
immediate entry yeah they they have a
really really good relationship with
Sega
like a really good relationship with
here comes a new Challenger
this has been a really good show so far
do you think the witch is really here in
this hotel
what is this
just nod and say Yes I'd never lie to
you
[Music]
[Applause]
what is this
look servant isn't this interesting
is that
I don't I I gotta turn it down guys
sound some music in the background
this looks good though
you know you find a shark
you guys know how I like boss fights
this looks pretty interesting
sorry I had to turn the the volume down
guys
this looks good
this is better than the state of play
I'd agree
that was a very good showing of
something
yeah
don't you love how they're constantly
using The Shining
foreign
all right
if they would have gonna do that they
would have done it without talking about
Traveler
foreign
[Music]
oh man I'm tired guys I'm going right
back to bed after this okay
I think we'll end up with a fun action
game it looks good I think it's been a
little too long on this conversation but
it looks good
[Music]
foreign
yeah probably not I think they're done
with the square announcements
foreign
[Music]
how we feeling
I need you guys's opinion man how we
feeling
are we feeling good about what was shown
how we feeling
we feeling good
better than baby steps
there I'd say I give it like a seven out
of ten seven eight out of ten because I
actually felt like that was a solid show
it didn't have a whole lot for me in
particular but I felt like it was a
solid show
I
would have preferred
you know a little bit more
like in terms of stuff that I wanted now
obviously we didn't get the the
the stuff that everyone wanted clearly
you know
it's unfortunate but
oh my God these cats man
uh it was a good show
I don't know why I have like a yellow
tint
it feels like
whoa
I don't know we're not gonna go into
that
but I'm curious curious what you guys
have to say I I think it was a good show
I do
you know I would have preferred
them to I guess you could I I didn't
like what they ended on I I felt like
that was a good that was a good game
good interesting game but I felt like
they could have interested they could
have ended it on something a little bit
more
like
what the hell moment I think they could
have ended on that but I get it I get it
I don't think it was a bad show though I
think it was a solid show and I think
you guys uh
definitely
should uh it was worth it was worth
watching
it was worth watching for sure
did they show that other Capcom no
I don't think anything there was news
people
I don't understand what people expected
from this
you know I had my I got octopath
traveler too and that that that that's
going to keep me decent that octopath
traveled to
I'm kind of curious like what were you
expecting from this
can someone explain that to me
what was the people that was
disappointed expecting from it like all
October traveler 2 by itself was a w to
me I feel like people
if you've got some crazy expectations
when it comes to like news that they
didn't really hype this up too much
but I felt like they did what they were
supposed to
nah Jabara I don't think um I think
seven will come sooner than that
uh I feel you expected more Game Pass
games
I'm okay with less Game Pass games uh as
long as games are actually coming to the
platform because that's important to
make sure games actually come to the
platform
but they all the old Final Fantasy is
already on the platform
so it's like I don't know
I'm kind of like wondering
because they're already on it
you guys get what I'm saying like
they're already on it
pixel remasters would have been nice
those are the only final fantasies like
the older ones that start on it
well I I feel you guys I feel you guys
you know there's definitely other things
they could have done like no one's
denying that I feel like octopath
traveler 2 coming uh to Xbox and
um the Yakuza game coming to Game Pass
is like huge momentum moments
yeah I liked it more than that state of
play because I really didn't like that
state of play I know like Jabari because
I know he's in the chat I know he loved
the state of play uh but you know
that state of play was good because
Final Fantasy was there but when you put
it on it's like merits like it didn't
really
it didn't really do a whole lot like on
its own if that makes sense
even within three that would have been
nice
there's a lot of things they could have
done
if I'm gonna go and end this
I'm gonna make a video for my personal
YouTube channel and then go back to bed
because I'm exhausted
yeah no Final Fantasy 7 but we got that
octopath traveler too it's like I said
that was that was the minimum I needed
from them was just octopod traveler too
but I appreciate everyone for coming
through here I would like to send you
guys to uh someone but unfortunately
there's not really many options to go
like people need to to turn on that
feature more often there's a feature you
have to turn on that lets me raid people
but I for some reason like no one has it
on like no one has it on
it's unfortunate
because I'm looking now
like I can't send you guys to anyone
that I would send you to
uh yeah I'm gonna play uh octopus travel
too I've been meaning to play
to play it but I I I just got
cyberpunk
and I and I want to really play that
it's Sega Atlas showcase yeah there's a
lot of um showcase there there was
definitely a lot of showcase there but I
I think it was a solid a solid thing it
showed me that Microsoft is getting
better in terms of like Japanese support
now obviously if you take that extremely
seriously you're gonna need another
platformer you know maybe PC to a an
extent to really be able to play these
games but I do think it was a solid
experience
yeah and then uh if you guys don't mind
you know here's here's my last video on
my personal YouTube channel definitely
go over there watch that video
and uh so so to my personal Channel man
I would appreciate it rate it from a one
to ten I'd rate it like a like a seven
maybe an eight because octopi traveler
two is really big for me and I really
wanted that so seven eight I think
that's a it was a solid show it was a
solid show if they would have like a
more stuff that meant to me I probably
would have gave it like a eight or nine
but octopod traveler 2 was really the
only thing that I cared about
or what
yeah so it was a good experience I think
I think people should be happy with it
these kittens are going crazy yeah
yeah you guys uh you know think
Dragonheart Yogi because there's a
couple people but he was the one that uh
they responded and I was like you know
what let me go ahead and just stream
this but hit that like button on the way
out guys and don't go it's like I said
man
go over to to my channel and sub to it
I'm trying to get that to 6 000 Subs by
the end of the year I think it's
possible but we'll see but until next
time this is gaming addict I'm out of
here peace see you this weekend
we're having Peter Moore on it's going
to be interesting
go sub to my channel guys